bonjour bruno mégarde merci d'être avec
nous ce matin à sur rt france à leur
première question tout simplement la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants
est ce que selon vous c'est une bonne
idée est ce que vous en parlez entre
vous entre soignant oui c'est une bonne
idée effectivement le soignant est une
personne qui a décidé d'apporter des
soins aux personnes fragiles malades qui
confient leur santé en coûts de sécurité
et donc effectivement il n'est pas
concevable que nous puissions
transmettent une pathologie grave
potentiellement mortel à des personnes
malades
donc effectivement il faut absolument
éviter ce risque et la vaccination
permet de réduire la transmission de la
colline il est donc absolument
indispensable que tout me soigne ans
soient vaccinés alors en italie c'est
déjà le cas les soignants sont obligés
de se faire vacciner dans le cas
contraire ils sont menacés de suspension
de salaire et même laurent poinçon sont
menacés est ce que ce n'est pas allé un
peu trop loin cette fois alors je dirais
bon je ne peux pas dire quelles qu'elles
pourraient être les sanctions à prendre
si une personne soignante refusé de
signer alors que l'obligation été
décidée par les autorités sanitaires
en pratique il est probable que une
étape intermédiaire serait de réaffecter
cette personne soignante vers des tâches
administratives ou logistique sans
contact direct avec les patients
mais il est vrai que les sanctions
seront aussi à décider en fonction du
nombre de personnels ne souhaitant pas
malgré tout être vaccinés car comme vous
le savez à l'hôpital public nous
manquons de personnel soignant
évidemment il ne faudrait pas qu'en
retire à un certain nombre de personnels
on se retrouve dans la difficulté ainsi
l'intégralité des soignants étaient
vaccinés ça permettrait aussi à
l'intégralité des effectifs d'être
présent c'est ça oui tout à fait
effectivement il ya un absentéisme
important qui pourrait être qui pourrait
apparaître si du personnel étaient
infectés malade il faut évidemment
compter une dizaine de jours d'isolement
en cas de contamination par la commune
19 et on a vu lente et trois vagues
précédentes certains services ont eu des
difficultés de fonctionnement en raison
de ces de cet absentéisme à nouveau il
ne faudrait pas stigmatiser le personnel
soignant qui malgré tout aujourd'hui
reste beaucoup plus vacciner que le
reste de la population
mais il est vrai un pourcentage
important hésitent encore et je crois
qu'il faut d'abord utilisé tous les
arguments de conviction pour pouvoir
leur expliquer l'intérêt est surtout
l'absence de dangerosité de se faire
vacciner
justement vous parlez d'arguments pour
convaincre peut-être les le personnel
soignant les plus réticents pour
l'instant qu'elle pourrait être l ses
arguments et est ce que l'état peut être
un rôle à jouer dans une campagne auprès
des auprès des soignants
oui tout à fait le premier argument le
plus important c'est l'efficacité
effectivement il n'ya plus aucun doute
le vaccin est parfaitement efficace pour
prévenir de la maladie notamment des
formes graves et mortels d'ailleurs quel
que soit le variant en question le
deuxième point c'est évidemment de
l'efficacité pour réduire la
transmission là aussi on a désormais
beaucoup d'arguments pour penser que le
fait de vacciner réduit la charge virale
et donc le risque de transmission à
l'autre troisième point c'est évidemment
l'innocuité de ce vaccin aujourd'hui
quasiment 3 milliards d'humains sous
vacciner et bien sûr il existe quelques
effets secondaires aux mineurs mais il
n'y a pas de gros danger à se faire
vacciner et enfin évidemment d'un point
de vue rationnel il n'y a aucune raison
de penser que des effets secondaires
inattendus à moyen ou long terme
pourraient apparaître
à nouveau des vaccins notamment à base
d'arn messager sont des vaccins
parfaitement naturel sans
immunostimulant sans aucun danger de
déclencher des maladies auto immunes
d'autres complications
alors on entend de plus en plus un
possible quatrième vague
d'ici là la fin de l'été peut-être même
à la rentrée
est ce que si l'intégralité d'aidé
soignant était vaccinée justement cette
quatrième vague pour être atténuée alors
non il faut pas penser que la
vaccination des soignants va modifier la
le risque de survenue d'une quatrième
vague
en fait c'est la vaccination de la
population générale qui pourrait le
faire malgré tout la vaccination massive
des soignants pourrait être un élément
déclencheur pour beaucoup qui hésitent
encore à se faire vacciner en voyant
évidemment que les personnes aux
responsabilités de des soins se faisait
complètement vaccinés pour pouvoir
éviter cette quatrième vague en pratique
dissocier la progression des
contaminations que nous attendons fait
d'un virus plus contagieux de la
progression des cas d'infections graves
avec une possible mise en tension des
hôpitaux
c'est la vaccination d'abord les
personnes âgées et à risque de faire des
foires de graves notamment porteuse de
comorbidité et deuxièmement c'est la
vaccination massive de la population
pour pouvoir atteindre l'immunité
collective et donc c'est sur ces deux
axes évidemment qu'il ôte absolument
jouer pendant des deux mois goûter car
évidemment si à la rentrée un
pourcentage important d'adultes
n'étaient pas vaccinés si l'immunité
collective était encore très faible
nous risquerions bien sûr revivre ce que
nous avons connu cette année
merci beaucoup bruno meier ban avoir été
avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt frange
rappelle que vous êtes chef du service
de réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière
à paris merci beaucoup